our series a more perfect union aims to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us a
recent CBS News poll finds 68 percent of
Americans feel the tone of political
debate is getting worse Dana Jacobson
shows us how one group hopes a simple
meal and meaningful conversation can
reverse that trend Dana good morning
good morning for ages people have been
sitting down together to share a meal
the perfect gathering space for food at
least that's how three motivated women
recently saw it making a push to bring
us back to the table hoping that brave
space as they call it would bring us
back to civil discourse as well Cheers
at first this may seem like just another
dinner party but listen closely to do is
around the table I pledge to listen
deeply to there's something different
here even though there was a language
barrier you could tell that she really
cared and loved you know me for who I
was this is a people supper where food
fosters a conversation sparked by
questions like this what could you also
pick out maybe now that was lacking or
missing in that picture answers emerged
organically in my childhood I never got
the experience of being a black American
but all these white people I wanted me
to be a black American the only doll
that kind of looked like me was an
Eskimo doll
what was the intent behind how you
wanted the dinners to be we wanted
people to see each other as people first
and foremost
easier said than done easier said than
time right
Emily Mae is one of three women who
created the people supper along with
Lennon flowers and Jennifer Bailey
motivated by the post-election divide
the original concept was to bring small
diverse groups together for a shared
meal suddenly there was this moment
whether born of having family or friends
who voted differently and not knowing
how to have that conversation or
actually not knowing anybody with a
different kind of political orientation
there was this real desire and to hear
it's clear to me that our nation is
existing at a time where there's a lot
of wounded people and hurt people we had
to hurt people and yet the three of you
wanted to bring them together to sort of
not hurt why our goal is to change the
expectation of judgment and the instinct
that we have to assume the worst in
somebody else the dinner started after
the inauguration with a goal of 100
dinners in 100 days but the group has
now fostered almost 250 dinners in 57
cities and towns each meal has a
volunteer host who gets direction in
leading the conversation the biggest
problem so far finding enough political
diversity with more progressives than
conservatives taking part because they
fear this is a vehicle through which
progressives are going to convince them
to change their beliefs starting from a
place of debating politics from debating
issues rather than story automatically
puts people's walls up it's like
starting from the head it's starting
from the head instead of the heart first
you have to develop a layer of trust
with one another to know that this
person sitting across from me with
cookies on the table all right
that person's not gonna attack me we
have to be able to have a civil
conversation before we can actually
discuss the tough things I had this
moment of hyperventilation like Shana's
a white cop
I can't I can't do this it's what the
women call a breed space by the end of
the evening I was like no Shana Shana
like she's not a white cop she's a whole
living person something we saw firsthand
and when I wanted to know what she
thinks about black lives matter I just
asked her Finn we had a really good
conversation we did I think that makes
me happy that that was shattered
Elise part of it I mean I am a white cop
do you think when you have some major
differences that these initial
conversations can also be a start we'd
like to believe the other person is kind
of like the enemy or the opposite right
just instead of objective izing the
other person it's like just get to know
them and I think everything else will
work itself out
the people suffer continues to grow
recently announcing that they're going
into a virtual space as well to host
dinners and the organizers told me
they've heard from people in almost 400
cities and towns who want to sit down
for a meal like this and the goal now is
just to keep the conversation going it
seems so simple sit down have a
conversation but that's where you have
to start to really hit the heart it's
interesting in the piece I think a lot
of people will feel very similarly to
that woman who says it's about
understanding the whole living person
and not trying to convince somebody to
change their mom you don't always have
to win you can have a conversation
listen yeah thank you very much